Hello? Hello? Hello? Hello? Can you yell? How are our volume levels?
Mic test 1, 2, 3. Should we all just yell? Yes.
I'm so sorry. Did we peek? I don't know.
All right. Reflins are reporting. They're saying hi mom. Right? But is hi mommy equal that the volume
levels are good? Come on. You'll need to tell me. They want louder? All four are clear and loud.
They say that someone says all sound is extremely loud. But if we're all equally extremely loud.
It's surely even. Yeah. Put it down a wee bit. By a whole three or four decibels, I'll put it down.
You're welcome. Okay. Let me see. Let me bring up the girlies. Okay. I hope everything is good on my end.
Apparently I'm peeking really badly. But I don't know how to fix that. So I'll just wait.
I'll wait for next stream. Well thanks for the next one. It sounds fine. I just kind of lowered
you a bit on this story. Yeah. It's not fine for my stream. It's okay. Whatever.
Do you have a limiter on your microphone? The plug-in? Yeah. The filters.
I do. I do. I try to turn it off. Turn it off? Yeah. Why turn it off? Because for me what happened
back in the day when I was using limiters is it just made my voice like peak hard. Oh. Really?
Okay. Yeah. It's really weird. I turned it off. Yeah, a lot of us. Did that help chat? Did it make
it worse? Did it help? Did it make it worse? I don't know. If we think we can progress, I must demand
gunpoint. Everyone introduce themselves. Okay. Right. Don't point blank at me. Only I won't let the gun.
Oh yeah. We have guns. Yeah. Guns. Who's going first? Who's going first?
Right. Are you all pointing at me? Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Force me. Force me. Yeah. Go. Go.
Hi. I'm Mimi Bizzou from from Village Generation One in Dulce. Yeah. Nice to meet you. Nice to
meet you. Yeah. Perfect. Perfect. Thales. Oh, I need a gun. Over on one. Hi. I'm Fuyo.
Culverfield. Wish granting leprechaun a vinyl. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Jenna. I have a gun. Oh, she got a gun.
But do you have a license to carry? Whoa. Whoa. What flashed? The gun. The gun. The gun. Guns in
space. I see you. Hello. My name is Juno Nagi. I'm also from Idol Corpse First Generation
Isakai and I'm going into November. Let's go. Yeah. Yeah. And then hello. I'm Stony Culls from
Village Generation One in Dulce and I'm Scottish and I'm sorry if you can't understand that accent.
Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello.
Today we are playing a game called Kill It With Fire 2. We have just completed the tutorial
which means that we can do campaign mode together. We have an assortment of tools to expel this ship
as we got abducted like moments ago and basically we need to expel. No more spiders. Spiders forbidden.
No more. No more. Spiders be no more. No more spider. Fuck them spiders. There were a couple of
spiders in the ship so if you're wondering why everything is a mess that's why. Yeah. Yeah.
We have to get rid of them. A couple spiders. Corpse is everywhere. Yeah. I do not like spiders.
I don't think any of us have played beyond this point so what happens after this is what happens.
No idea. Total spider annihilation. I'm sorry. What happened? I'm sorry. Oh god it's over.
Wait no more fire. I almost killed them because I was just lighting fire to stop.
Right. Okay. No more fire. I will use fire with purpose. I promise. I will use fire with purpose.
So are we ready to go out? Are we ready to go? Yeah. I'm ready. I'm at the hangar door.
Okay. Okay. Okay. The glowing one. So wait we are exterminators from space? I think so.
Oh my god there's a spider there. Did you see it? Where? Where? Where's the spider? Kill it. Kill it.
I'm burning everything. Yeah. So oh. Good job to. Burn it to death. There's a morph? What's a morph
Spider? Oh what's this? Oh what? What is that? Oh that's the spider. Oh god it's big. Get it. Get it. Get it. Get it. Get it. Get it.
Bitch. Okay. Did it die? Don't you see it back in the spider? Yes. Another one. Another one. What the heck?
Wow. Okay. Wow we're so good at this. Clearly the shooting skills are off the door.
Return the weights to the rack? Oh it's the rack. Oh my. Do you even lift bro? Do you even lift? No I don't.
Wait this is the recorder. Ah there's another one. Oh my god. What the hell? Hey. Wait they're cheating. Is it dying?
Yeah it's dying. Okay good. There we go. Okay. Right we're putting them in a. While you guys are doing that
I'm gonna find the weights. There's the weights. There's the.
I can listen to music finally. Wait you can hear? I can listen to music. Oh it's a crew log. Never mind. Fuck that.
No one wants to hear that shit. Fuck that. What the hell? I love organizing. Oh I got more ammo for the flamethrower.
Oh another. What's this? Seat pod thingy move over. I think that's how we open the hangar doors what you just found in me.
I see. Oh. What? We need to turn that off. Does anyone know where the other weight racks are? We're missing two
weights. Turn the weights. Yeah. Oh I found one. I found one. We need one more. Oh we can also go through here. We need one more.
The store opened. Oh I'm searching for the spoons. We need one more. We need one more white.
Oh there's a tape here. I'm stuck. You're stuck? It's okay.
Bring the tape back. Where's the last? I don't know. I can't find it. And the tape. Oh wait no it's what?
What you done? Where's the last? I got a laser gun. A laser gun? A laser gun. Wait only you get to keep it.
How do you drop it? Is there a way to drop it? Oh it does share. Oh it's shared? If you press cute.
If you press cute right I'm taking the gun off and putting the laser on. Where's the last? Where's the last?
Where's the last one? The weight. Wait hold on I'm coming back to help you with the weight because. Where's the last one?
Is there anything I can shoot? There's a bunch of weights over here. Oh wait that's where we're putting it.
That's Ruthie. Are they behind the freaking plant? Paul it's out. You come. I'm trying to shoot them.
I found it. It was right here. I found it. Oh my god we did it. Oh there's another one.
Oh another. It's more compionics. Yeehaw. Nice. Yeehaw. Okay so then we're all good right?
No more spiders or objectives in this room? I mean aside from over here but. I think so.
We can come need one more bag for that. Okay we can continue doing this cheeky holy.
See if I have Scottish. That's what I always say. I was like Stranny keep speaking. I need to hear that.
I need to hear. I need to hear your voice. I was explaining I was like I don't really like using
slang too much in case people don't understand me but I can make my accent like super hard to
understand if you want. Do it. Do it. Do it. Do it. Do it. Do it. Right all four of us are entered the
hangar. We're currently hunting the spiders. We've no got a clue what's about to whack them but we're
gonna get our job done and then we'll get our paycheck and we'll get out of here. Yes. Whoa.
My cup just exploded. No it's okay. There we go. Bridge and the hangar.
Is this one? It's okay. I could understand you. I think you could just speak how we want to speak.
Yeah everyone understood you. Don't worry. Yeah. All right this is my parents. This is
actually my real voice. I'm sorry I've been mucking about for three months with that voice. I can't
be offshore anymore. All right where's your Spillidosk one?
You'll see. Oh we need this assembler. I've just done fast travel somehow.
Collect audio logs. A refund says you're so good at accents. No that's just my actual accent.
That's not that I'm good. Right who wants to stand in the teleporter because I'm too scared.
I'll do it. It's over by me. I'm jumping up and down on the spot. If you come up,
I think this is a teleporter and before you stand on it. No I thought the teleporter was,
I thought the tele, oh okay. Where are you? I'm back home. Wait at the start of the map?
Yeah yeah. Oh it must be if you forget an objective and want to come back to do 100%.
Yeah. Yeah. Not the game devs being friendly. This game's early access. Like they've not finished
it but if the game devs are friendly like this, 10 out of 10. Oh and there's another one here.
I don't know how to turn on the c-powered conduit. Okay so we need to find stuff to fix the teleporter
right here. The big one. And I think we need to visit the other rooms. Yeah. Our objective is
debug the gate's power converters. This is a bit above my pay grade. This wasn't really what I
signed up for. I was just to do the spider killing. Okay. Oh I got an achievement. What did you do?
Solve a hard puzzle. Who did that? I don't know. Who did that? You solved the riddle? I guess. Wow.
I was just clicking buttons. Oh my god. What is this? I thought it was a key card maybe. It looks like a
but. Wow. Okay. There's other places that we can go that's not this room I think. Is there?
I think yeah there's another. Yeah. Data chip missing. We're missing a data chip. Oh wait we
have a data chip. That thing that- Wait wait you? That little data chip? I think it's on the floor.
It goes here. It goes where? I don't know. It looks like it. I don't know. I don't think this is it.
Let me see. Why is that thing lighting up? I got the data chip. You'll never guess.
I think. Nice. You got a data chip. Return to the terminal to activate this terminal. Is this the
terminal? Does everyone get access to that data? I would assume everyone gets access. Only the host
may perform this action. Amir? Click that screen. Your finger that screen right now. Go. Which one?
Up here. Up. Up. Activate. The big activate. The big one? Oh shit look. My sensors have detected
an abnormal concentration of spiders within a construction site. What? Known as Artois
Manor along with a human space fleet? Data chip real king. Look at me. Junna don't do it. Junna!
Wait what happened? My screen died. Junna like moonwalked into a portal and my screen went black.
Oh god. Oh no. There's fire webs. Oh get the get the. Oh do fire. Do fire. They're everywhere.
They're everywhere. Do fire. Oh no. Kill. Kill. Kill them. Fire. Fire. Lay everything up. Kill.
We're actually just secretly arsonists on our time off. Please they're gone. Burn webs. Okay.
Are they dead? I think they did it. Oh wait no that was a. What?
How many webs do you? Oh we need four more. Four more cobble webbles. What the
frik is this supposed to be? What? Can we open doors? Is this a normal table or? There's a door
over here that we can go through. Oh it's a frikkin deer. Oh it's a deer. I want to play a game.
I want to play a game. Oh we can open that chest now. Oh the one we. Oh you guys are over there. Oh
yeah there's a chest. Yeah. Wait where did you guys go? There's a tank door here that we can open.
Why is this house so creepy? Guys there's a vacuum. There's a vacuum. Everybody there's a vacuum.
Oh it's a cauldron. A vacuum? Which v-tubers rise up. A vacuum there. Can you guys get there?
Wait. A door open. Can you guys see the spider or am I. Is there a spider on me that you can see?
I suck it. Oh yeah. Yes I killed it. Oh my gosh. Okay thank you. I sucked it.
This looks like a massive ten foot spider randomly. Take it away. Don't worry about it.
We got you Bresty. Oh we have to brew the potion. Bresty. Oh shit oh shit we got there's some little
hooligans over here. Two fires for a simmer. Three for a bolt. We have to fire up the
one, two, three. Use the ladle to stir. I'm saving some for later. Where's the ladle? I'm stirring.
Oh Stranny has it. Stir it up. I'm stirring the absolute crap. It's actually working.
Call me Gordon Ramsay because I'm cooking. Not all ingredients are in this room.
I start too much. What's supposed to happen? It wasn't me. It wasn't me on Ecamp River. It wasn't
me. I wasn't on the leader. Oh the sweet. Oh I think we might need to find another cauldron but uh.
Wait it's not just going to respawn. I don't know. That's not how the world works.
Cauldrons just don't respond. How to reset your cauldron. Leave the room close to the door behind
you. Spin three times in a circle counterclockwise. Oh okay okay okay. Yeah and we have to make this potion
so. Wait we need to get out. Okay counterclockwise. Spin three times. Two, three, four. Oh my god it's there.
Oh that was really creative. I'm going to give them that right. I'm not going to mix it too hard this
time. Okay so we just need to have two fires. Okay so we have the two. Okay so we need an
Ivan noot and a butterfly wing. I'm assuming this is a noot eye. Or is this a frog eye? The only
alchemy experience I have is from Skyrim and this ain't like Skyrim. Okay I guess. Never leave the
label in the cauldron. Oh that's what I did. Oops not all ingredients are in this room. Oh we're
going to have to go find. So I think this is the bead on and we need the butterfly wing.
Wait where are you guys seeing the straw? Okay never mind I'm blind. They're on the wall.
Wait I'm an extinguished fire. Only two fires are on which we need. Yes only two we only need two.
There's just two don't worry. Never. I added more. Oh no no but only two are on so you're fine.
Okay no oh wait and then what the ingredients are in here. One small mushroom? Yeah I already I
already put in the. And the eye of a noot. You put in the. I put the noot eye and the butterfly
and the beetle in there but we need a butterfly. Oh a butterfly wing. Okay and we have to wait until
it turns brown. He at a boil. Don't put the mushroom. No. I thought you were supposed to be
in a witchcraft. What's going on here? Hold on a minute. I thought it was your lore. I'm sorry.
Are we doing a cheeky 360? Everyone out. Okay okay okay let me. Maybe we just let Junna do it.
She seems to get it. I'm like Junna's the smart one out of us. You're really good with all of
coming home. Let's really let her cook. Are you sure you're really free time as well because
god damn. I like cooking. Clearly. You're in your element. Okay so we have to do that and
it has to turn brown before we can add anything else. When. Watch it not work. And a little
mushroom right? And then what happens? Yeah. And we have to wait until that turns blue.
And then and then who wants to stir vigorously until it turns orange? As long as you don't hold
the ladle and I've not got any more. We have to wait for it to turn blue or unless I did it wrong.
No. I can't find the ladle though. Hello Mr. Ladle. I found it's right here. It's right here.
So you have to wait for it just to turn blue and then. Wait when's it going to turn blue?
I don't know. A boil. A boil is three flames. Is it on three flames? Yeah and there's three.
And I put that mushroom in so. Oh do we do it too quickly? Is that a spider's back?
Why did they make this so hard bro? I feel like this is actually really. This is like too many
cells for this. Can I go inside? The surf you want. Why are you boiling yourself?
So you can eat me. Oh the dining room got unlocked. Wow. And game's telling us to go elsewhere. God
damn you're kicked up. Like can we cook? Okay yeah we're just supposed to wait I guess but.
Right make it blue and then mushroom right? Surely. It's on for you. It's on for you.
It's on for you. Are you okay? Kill it. Kill it. Kill it. Kill it. I'm shit. I'm shit. Where are you?
Oh no that's true. No wrong one. I think it's off. I think it's off. Did it die? I think so.
Is it crawling on? What is spinning? God damn break it down. Can you see that physics? Or is it
just me that sees that? I think it's just you. No it's break dancing for me on my POV.
Hit him with a ray gun. Oh it's hard. There's like a skull here. Is it moving? Yeah.
And the light was off so I torched it and now it's on. Wow. Maybe it's a secret.
Maybe it's a secret if you lay them all off. Totally an original idea. Not chat help.
Did the lucky charms help be honest? No totally not. Tell us the truth. Tell us the truth.
We'll get out of here. We'll come back to the witch's cauldron. Yeah. Oh. I opened the door.
Oh this is our challenge. Oh. Anyone? Oh I'm out of ammo. Oh my god. It blinded me. It just
went on my face. There's a shotgun over here. There's so much happening.
Oh my god. It's like Minecraft when you walk through the spider web. It slows you down.
Oh we can open this door too. Oh I need the vacuum sucker. There's a spider on me I think.
Oh I killed it. Hold on. My fire thing doesn't work anymore. What now? It's over. What the hell?
Oh we'll need to find more ammo. How do you get rid of the... Oh no you... Oh a teleporter.
Great job. Use the nearby portal to return to the vindicator. Oh. But we can still collect stuff.
Beat them up Juno. Oh no Juno. Fucking fire. Fuck em up. Beat them up. I think it's dead. Okay.
What's this? I'm just gonna lay there so... How do we get... How do we get more fire? The hell?
Juno's... Oh upstairs. Right. I don't... Yeah. No.
God there's so much. This game is humongous. Humongous what?
This game is far too big. I'm so sorry. I literally thought it was going to be like one
simplistic level. We have teleported to a different realm. We're on a spaceship that is about to go
back. How do I burn this down? How do I burn this down? Oh there's something else here.
I need to find more... Let us in. Let us in. No. So this door doesn't work. I want to shoot it.
It didn't work. Access to the bedroom and bathroom. Yes. For you. Oh for me thank you.
Oh I love it. I love it so much. Oh I'm romantical. There's more here.
Oh for me. Oh my gosh it's yellow as well. It's so cute.
If you guys come back down, there's a challenge thing. But Amy has to open it.
If you guys want to follow me real quick, come here.
Kill Smarter's a sniper rifle. Where's the sniper rifle?
Did anybody get a sniper rifle? I did. Oh Fire Emel. There's more Fire Emel here.
I don't know if anybody saw it. Where are you? Where are you? Here here here. Oh and
Oh did you pick it up for all of us? No maybe you did it. I don't know. It only went to you.
Oh okay then I'm gonna get rid of the... Okay so come here come here.
I can't get rid of all of these.
Extinguish hallway candles while evading the spider statue. What are we playing like the...
How do we extinguish it? Is it gonna follow us? I don't know. Is this weeping angels with spiders?
Oh you do have to put fire on it. It's starting to get real. Everybody get ready. Everybody get ready.
I'm sniping it. Is it gonna start chasing us? I think so. Oh yeah there's okay. Oh extinguish them.
So we have to take the fire away. I extinguish too. I ran out of fire. Jenna you're actually
100 IQ. You like everything right off the bat. We did it. Is it weeping angel? Yeah it is.
I looked away and then it got me. We did it. Oh okay let me see. I'm already down with this situation.
Wait we did it? I literally did not 500 IQ. You died? That's okay. No. Wait are you dead?
You're alive. Can you not see us? Yes. I want to kill the spiders with the sniper rifles because
if you kill five then you get another date. Come here. I have one too. Oh you have one.
The thing works. I did have one. There's a skull here. Skull skull skull. Can I give? Light them up.
Light them up. I don't know where to find more spiders. I'm empty. I'm empty.
Yeah. Light this up. Yeah light it up. Yeah. What does it do? I have no idea. Open something.
Kill spiders with rifles. Right I'm looking for sputters. There has to be. Okay okay. There's a
pooter. I don't know how to find them. Wait here here here. There's a spider here. In the corner
somewhere. Oh it's in the clock. It's in the clock. It's in the clock. It's in the clock. It's in the
clock. Hold on. Hold on. I've got the rifle out. I've got the rifle out. Here get it. Kill it. Kill it.
Oh my god. That's a little pin. Give me the rifle. Someone give me the rifle.
How did you do that? Press Q to equip the rifle. Press Q to equip it. It should be like right
side middle. Did you kill it? No no. It's under the piano. Piano. Piano. Chair. Chair. Chair.
It's under the freaking chest. Okay red seat. Red seat. Red seat. Red seat. Double seat. Single.
Yes. Yes. Oh my gosh. I don't think we need a you don't I don't think you just zoom in. I think
it's pretty accurate. I guess. Maybe. We're all in a boat though. Okay. I'm out of ammo for my sniper.
This game. Okay. It's stuck. Oh there's another flame. Wait is this a the vent? Let me try to do
this. I've a newt. Stop it. You're turning the fire off Mr. Vent. There's an OSC. I don't know how to
turn the vents off. And a beetle. Interference. There's a morph spider nearby. Right. It's almost
something. A morph spider. Oh it's one of those big ones. Yeah that come from items. Oh no.
Are you a morph spider? Identify yourself right now. I'm so confused. Is this is this
the small mushroom? Nope. Have we done this? Nope. The mushroom is probably like a big shroom.
No. No. Really? No. It was a tiny one but now there's no more small ones. Did they respawn
every time we respawn in the cauldron? There's there's one right here. Is it is it one of these?
No. No. That's a bit regular sized one. So it's a big one. I think was I think what it was it
didn't turn blue once it turns. Oh wait. No. No. Actually you're right. Heat until it turns brown
then at the mushroom. Yeah and then yeah. Oh it says heat. Oh royal rolling. A rolling boil? Oh I
guess four is rolling boil. Uh does that mean put the flames back to on a simmer? No I think it was
like I had to put all four on. Okay. Okay. I'm ready to do some. Oh there is one. Okay get out. Get
out. I'm a I'm a spin on it clockwise. Okay we got this. We got this. Is it? Okay. Okay. I'm just
I'm a new Emily. Yeah. Stand back. Stand back. It says there's spiders here but they're all dead.
It's and no that's what I'm saying. Main says there's one right in front of me.
Yeah but they're dead. Yeah I don't know how to find them. They're pretending to be dead. All right.
Oh he's on me. Well if anyone wants to see the spider he's mine.
Got him. Yeah you're just you're just being the show. I mean it. Sorry.
That you got him 10 wax to go thanks. Is this what I supposed to do? Oh it's blue. You did it.
Is this what I supposed to do? Oh. No it's to turn orange. Is this what I supposed to do?
Bring to Rumble until it turns blue. Stir vigorously until potion turns orange.
Stir vigorously until potion turns blue.
Stir vigorously until potion turns orange.
Come on. Fang them up. Let her cook. Let her cook.
Keep going. Keep going. Oh my god. But don't leave the ladle in. Don't leave the ladle in.
Or else it'll explode. You have to stir vigorously but from the outside.
It looks like it's not going inside from my POV like you're just in 360s around it hoping for the best.
Oh like this. Okay. Row vigorously. How is this? How is it not?
Is it registered in that? I don't know. This one's just going crazy for me.
It's like this. Oh wait. No. Can you rotate it like the bottom of it to go in?
Oh I can hear it splashing so you are doing it. Yeah. Make it splash vigorously.
I like how it will stand back just in case it explodes again. We're like not trusting it.
I don't want to mess it up. How is that not done? Is this a prank? Are you being pranked?
I'm sorry. Does it need to be in the cauldron? I feel like it might need to be in the cauldron.
Stir vigorously until it turns orange. It's in the cauldron for me.
Ball potion with E. Who was the ball? Oh my god. Firmly compressed it.
I got spider potion. It's like a new one. We've got grenades for scooters now.
Where is it? Oh spider potion. A new thing opened. Yay. I'm more confident. Nice.
That was so hard. What are you doing with the spider potion though? I think it's a grenade.
Oh my god. For you. What have you done? Get a spider.
Everybody please grab this clue. Don't do it. Please don't do it. She's so tiny.
She's so cute. What the? Oh there you go. Oh you're back. I'm just touching this potion again.
Are we supposed to go in the vents or something for that? Oh maybe. Oh that's so smart.
Wait hold on. I'm chugging. Don't mind me. I'm off. Go in the vents. How do I jump on a wall?
What? It looks like it worked for a second. Oh. Oh I didn't. Wait can I go again? What about the
bigger one? What about this one? What's this? Heavy ammo. Ammo. Ammo. I can't go back to being a wee
spider again. Doesn't really do it. Oh wait. I tell the lies right. Excuse me. I'm off.
So like can you can you go refill the spider potion? I assume. I can lunge apparently. And then I can
What is this? Oh wait. Can you go? Wait wait. Stroney come here. Can you go here?
Can you go in through here? Wait. There's a phone. Oh the bathroom. Oh fuck. Yeah.
Can you go in the bathroom again? Hold on. Let me try. Everyone there's a phone and it's shining.
Take it. Oh there's a timer. Hold on. There's a timer but I know exactly what you mean. I think
I'm going to open the door from the other side. Someone says accurate leprechaun size.
Reef land. Nice. Oh yeah this was it. Hold it. Hold it. Hold it. Hold it. Hold it. Hold it. Hold it.
We did it. We did it. I got it. It's like I can't. I can't open the door. There we go.
Oh there's a spider in here. Come here. Where? It's on me. I just throw a nail gun at you.
You'll be fine. You'll be fine. You'll be fine. It's on me. Okay. Okay that one.
Oh there's different types of portions we can brew. More? I may have broken that. It's shining.
Oh. Do we need to say we spin again? We're different types of things. We need to access the bedroom.
Okay there we go. Where's the bedroom? This one? There's no hole in to get inside though.
There is the. There's the. Whoa. Oh there's a more spider. That was who was in this area.
Stop it. Spank that naughty spider. It's got so much vitamins in it. He's so healthy.
It's got what? Vitamins. Vitamins. Oh how'd you say it? Oh right.
Lay their souls to rest. What does that mean? Kill all the spiders. You mean the skulls?
Sanctity of the skulls? Huh. Sorry. I should have said flintstone gummies or whatever they're
called. That's right. I'm coming for you big flintstone gummies. I'm calling you up personally.
Oh. There's another one. Oh the shiny stuff. Bring them over to the people. Yeah. Oh the shiny
stuff here. Oh wait. Shiny. Bring them over to the people. Oh it's an offering. A tube of glue
and uh okay so we need two more shiny things. Uh huh. Uh where did this one goes here? There's
one kind of scattered around. How do we go outside? I've got a teapot. I don't know. Probably we have
Is anyone brish by any chance? Is any of them brish? Where are the other shiny things for y'all?
I don't know. I only found two. Or these two? Yeah. Okay hold on. If they were on this table then
yes. Wait only two. Okay. We need sparkly things for the momentum worry. Sparkle. Sparkle. Sparkle.
Sparkle. What is this? Right be a magpie. Sanctity and shiny. Sanctity and shiny.
We're all these people on the picture. They're the people who used to live in the house
for them. Did the space eat them? Probably. Maybe. They're vicious.
We need to find more sparklies. Shiny. Shiny. I'm having. How did you find two shinies in a row?
I don't know. I saw shiny. Because she's a leprechaun. Oh that real? Real. Her grubby little hands.
They're webbing me. They're webbing me. Where is it? Replay challenge. Absolutely no. I'm not
doing the weeping spiders from doctor. Maybe it could be inside of some drawer.
Maybe. Is it just me? Or the color is turning black? I think because we burnt it. It's because
we burnt it. Can you manually destroy cobwebs or does it have to be with fire? I think it has to
be with fire. Oh I think it also works with the, oh no never mind. I thought I could back you.
It's not working. It says there's a more spider right here. What the heck? Wait no, it's gone.
Maybe I'm behind something. Oh. Can I still turn into a spider? Yes. Come over here. Come over here.
Oh wait. I found the bedroom I think. I found the bedroom I think. Oh my god you are smart.
Is that another sparkle? It's up here. It's a hole. I drink. In the ceiling. Go go go.
You do. Foo you. Foo you. Foo you. Open the door for us. Go go go. Let's go. Oh is it?
I can do some sick jumps. Didn't you see that? You're getting some air. I'm not going to lie.
You're getting some air time. Yeah. Oh why did you jump off from the, oh.
Okay. You turned it into a human and jumping on the table was so cute. Oh my god. Wait why
does it cool down? Hold on. I'll try it. All right let's go. Go go go. You have to aim up. Oh
fuck oh. Am I going to get a shot? Sure. How do I do it? Number six. Number six.
Number six doesn't press Q and find the potion. Oh sorry. My number six. Okay.
Oh spider. Oh wait. Juna's going for again. Juna. Go Juna. In me. Juna. In me. Juna. Oh you have.
The first spider to get it. Wait. How do I jump? Oh you're a human again. Climb up walls?
That's so stupid. Wait only let's you like leap on the wall no more. Honestly thank god they can't.
What? Oh wow it really doesn't let you do that. What? How are you so there's another
game mode in this game where you like be the spider and hide from each other but we decided
to do the campaign but this is. I did it. Let's go. Let's go. Right. Can you open the door?
I think so. Hello. Oh my god. Hold on I'm directionally challenged. How did you make it there?
Up the stairs. To the left. To the left. I need to find one more shiny thing. More spider.
Beat him up. Kill it. Kill it. Kill it. Okay. I think it's dead. One more for good luck.
Another one. Oh wait. That's Juna. Okay. Wait does Juna count if we kill her? If we kill ourselves
with spiders? No. No. No. No. Maybe. No. It's a sacrifice I'm willing to make.
I need one more sparkly thing. Spider shaped.
And one in here. Dove it. Okay. Are you going ore? No it's a broom. Oh it looks like an ore.
Whoa that that is that looks like an ore for me. Oh. Spanky. There's a wrench. What's in here?
A weapon. Was the wrench sparkly? Money. Space box? There's currency.
I can't even see anything I'm webbed. What is that? Holy shit. It's a flint but it's spider shaped.
They go as they'll put it on the bed. They prank me bro. No. No. No. No. I'm destroying everything
Do you like the taste of that potion? Yeah I really do trust.
I need to find the last shiny. Yes. Oh yeah suck me for you.
Yeah. Does that intimidate you? Yes a bit.
Oh you need four potions? Oh you need four potions. Yeah I don't want to make more though.
It says needle drop. Play it again exterminator. What is that on the objective? It's on the other
page of the objective. How do you play it again exterminator? Was it this room?
Needle drop. Maybe it's the um. There's a record player here. Is it? Is it shiny? It's not shiny
but I look shiny doko. I keep accidentally drinking it. It's like second nature now.
I ironically did not make this easy. That's called an addiction Juno. Addiction. Oh I don't know what
how to respond. Do we have to go back to the potion room to make more potions? Yeah like the same one
over is. Can you do the same one over and over and over and it might count? I think it has to
be different ones. Does anyone have rifle ammo? Upgrade module? Oh wait I do.
Because we still have to kill spiders. We still have to kill former spiders with the rifle. There's
a spider here. There's one here on the chest. Strony look for Strony. Strony's tracking it. Beep beep
I'm following it. It's on me. It's on me isn't it? Shoot it. No it's here. It's here. It's on the floor.
It's on the floor. It's on the floor. Wait where did it go? Red cheer? Behind you.
Where would we find more recipes? Yes fire ammo. Did you get it? Okay nice. Yes three more left.
I assume they're going to keep responding. Hello hello. Wait do you guys have any idea
like where to find more recipes? In a book? There's a more spider in Juno's room to the
right somewhere. If you want to snipe it with a sniper it's like where? It's somewhere here.
It's teasing. It's teasing. Is it up here? It may be up. It may be up.
There he is. I got him. Oops he's here somewhere. There he is. Oh he's on me. Okay can you scope Juno
without taking her head off? I got him. I got him. I got him too. I got him too. Oh nice.
Nice. There is another job. There is another one as well in here because my jammer's still blocked.
Who is it? It's not random. You just smack everything. Literally I'm just touching everything.
Is it under the floor? I mean under the chair? Oh it could be. I found it. Oh right. What the?
Snape that motherfuckers. Snipe it. Oh he's stuck in here if you want to touch it. Touch it?
Yeah. And then there's one more behind us here somewhere behind the chair. I only have one more
bullet. No pressure. Oh no. I found it. It's on. It's on Emi. Can you snipe it with that?
Do you see it? It's on my face. This is one shot. It's on your back. It's moving a lot. Hold on.
Show me. Hold on. Hold on. Come on. Hold on. Don't move. Don't move. Don't move.
Kill me already. Oh my god. Yes. For you. That was amazing. Holy crap. Last freaking bullet. You did
it. That was amazing. Oh my god. We can unlock something now. I don't know what but something
on the map's not being unlocked because of that. Let me see. Oh not that we have to find. Maybe we
have to like light up all the candles quickly so that the thing doesn't shut them off. It's just
more compoundics. Oh. Oh wait with enough compound we can go outside. Oh to go up. Yeah. Yeah. Maybe
that's where the last shiny thing is. Yeah maybe. Here. Here. Here. Here. Oh wrong one. Where is it?
I sort of forgot. There was like a seven one somewhere. Oh. Is that bake following us? Am I going
crazy? Who is what following us? Wait where did you guys find the thing? The photography thing?
I don't know who but it wasn't me that found it. Oh I found that one. I found that one. You did? Yeah.
Okay so we're just missing one. We're just missing one. Yeah. No he goes in this
because he's an explorer outfit. That tricycle is moving. I'm not being funny. That tricycle's
moving. I don't need chocolate. You're right it is. That's fine. You guys are going crazy.
No it's totally moving. If you look away. I look away from the tricycle. I want to play a game.
Okay look in the way. Yes see. See. See. I told you I wasn't going mental. Okay okay stop looking at
it and just let's just see where it goes. I think it just tries to come up to us. It probably just
follows you. Oh my god it's right in front of you. Wait okay I'm sitting on the table as well.
I'm scared of that. I'm looking all the way but I'll be on the table. Where is it? Okay I'll look
away. Is it gonna take us to like some shadow realm if it touches us? Oh it's soft moving.
It's soft moving. I wonder if we're too close. It probably just follows us. Yeah we might be too
close to it. It just wants to play. It just wants friends. It's freaking moving while I'm looking at it.
It doesn't even care. I swear. I swear there was a room that was like you could open it once he had
like seven maybe. Oh it's I've got a twelve one here at the ball.
Is there any more holes in the ceiling that we can spider into maybe? Oh maybe maybe maybe.
I don't know what to do. Also does anybody have a way to remove like planks from the walls?
I don't know. It only lets us grab it when the nails are on the other side like if the nail
if you can visually see the nails I don't think we can take it. I see I see. Wait we have to play the
record? The record? Oh we got please hand hold please stream snipe please. Someone just said oh
nobody played the record yet. Wait hold on there was a record upstairs I was touching it.
All right I've got a record. Did we complete the challenge for sure? I don't think we completed.
Are you ready for some tunes? Yes. I got an achievement for that. Did it do anything?
Maybe we unlocked something because it said needle drop play game complete. Morph spiders around.
Yeah I'm gonna smack everything. Is that blocking us? It is who?
Who? Butterfucker. Wake up where the fuck are you? Literally we're smacking the absolute.
I said I'm becoming a spider and looking for the damn thing. Oh oh Mr. Spider. Where is it? Where is it?
Don't you know what some of this? Don't you want? Ow don't spank me. Don't you love my luscious eight
legs? I bet you want to get all up in that and use it. Maybe we can hear it. We'll make a little
nest together and then I'll eat you afterwards. You think you can eat all of me? All seven foot of me?
I can't find it. Oh maybe it's under the table. I'll become a spider. We still need to lay their
souls to rest. Yeah we need to find one more. Right there's not an under the table as well.
Where the heck is this Morph spider? Are you guys sure it's not upstairs? Because there's like a
question mark. Oh what happened? Oh sorry I went through the portal. Should I bring everyone? Yeah
yeah but don't worry. Oh I'm sorry! I thought you were just being weak. I don't think we lost any
progress. Welcome back. How do we go back there? With the recovered data ship you can now open the
portal to dimension lambada. Oh is it lambada a dance in Spanish or something?
I'll show you the lambada. In Portuguese that means like a punch like a slap.
Oh it's violence? Okay yeah it's violence. Oh no violence. There's a Morph spider somewhere here.
I wonder if everything's fixed or it's like so trashed. It'd be easier if it was fixed.
Where the fuck are we? We're giants? We're giants?
Oh my gosh. Giant test pros are winning right now. Holy moly.
Holy moly. Oh my god. This is my canon size by the way. Real and true though.
I remember when you came out. I love killing spiders. You can destroy the buildings as well.
Like straight up destroy them. That's so mean. I just removed the light poles.
Wait where's the spirit boat? No come back here. I saw you. Is that a mine? I'm in the mine.
Is there a restaurant on the side? Is there a restaurant on the side?
Someone sniped that whole air balloon. I'm shooting at it. Oh no.
I actually killed it. I didn't think they were going to actually. Wait what the heck?
Why is this so funny? The straw and zilla. That's so good. Oh my god. They're in the ground.
They're in the vents. They're in the hell. Get them.
Oh there's a pizza delivery guy. Pizza slider. Pizza time.
Hold on. I'm checking the radar. Oh wait this part is open.
What is this? I see it. I killed them. I'm so bad. I can smell you. Whoa. Hello Juno.
I love clean. Wait extension surgery. Is that what we got? Open hydrants.
We got our kneecaps broken and then like. How do you open hydrants? How come it's extended? Oh.
How come there's so many scooters? You're on the bottom. I'm going to go from a mansion to this.
I don't know. Open fire hydrant. I don't know how do you open the fire hydrants?
You press E on them. It's time to stop.
They're like screaming. I feel really bad. It's a stop sign. Do you see the stop sign?
Can you guys hear them scream? I feel really bad right now. Where's the stop sign? In my hand. In my hand.
I can't see the stop sign. You can't see the stop sign? I can't see the stop sign. It's right here.
I'm drowning all the spiders right now. Oh. How do you drown them? You go their cars in the water.
Oh yeah. I see one. I would shoot but my pistol like. Oh my god you can become a spider.
Not in this version. Spank them. I wish I wish I wish you could kill them as a spider. Spank them John.
Why is that spider taking out? What is this? It's a pizza. What's a pizza? Oh they have little
jobs in the city. Yeah. We are just ruining their lives or monsters. That's okay. That's okay.
Journal. We got journal. We're going to hit them with journal. Oh. I need a parkour.
This gives you like news whenever you kill one I think. That actually just
reminded me. I remember one time I begged my dad to kill a spider because I was too scared of it.
I was like eight years old and he was too scared to do it as well and I was like oh thank you.
Really? Both of us were too scared and I was like okay. What am I supposed to do now?
Thanks father. Never asked again for help with this bitter.
I mean at least the spiders don't have to go to work first thing in the morning.
Like we're doing them a favour because it's not 9am yet so really they didn't have to do a shift
and then die. They like oh my god it's got baker's hat on it but oh I now feel a little bit bad.
Do they have to pay spider taxes and webs or something? Probably. They're like that loaf of bread
oh no sorry that one fly that was 50 webs sorry. I want to be right back hold on. Okay.
Did you guys get oh I finished the auto destruction. Beautiful. We've got to burn billboards too.
They're like coming out of the ice cream shop screaming. Ground spiders okay. Wait the spiders
underground are wearing little hats oh my god. Yeah they're like a bakery hat. A tank.
I'm a tank. Oh how did you do that? I don't know I just saw it on the ground. Oh wait oh you can go and
say the time. I love drowning. I'm a tank. The eel would say that. I love drowning little shits.
All right I'm gonna just put all the cars away I guess. A tank.
Tank tank tank tank tank. Let me see collect spiders hats and other accessories uh.
How do the spiders even drive a car? I don't know. Their legs can't even fit inside.
Joan is somebody doing this correctly?
Collect spider hats. Oh my god what if there are children in there? Sample finest. Spider children.
Spider children. Oh you can molotov. You got molotov? Hold on a minute let me get that on.
Where's that me? Why am I blue? Why am I blue? How did they have so many weapons as well?
You were rude the day. Wait why am I going backwards?
I figured it out. I figured it out. We'd be burning everything.
I don't know what the purple building is that's highlighted over here.
Juno. I am a tank and I'm coming.
It will survive one big giant eel or a wee tank.
They work together. Defeat tanks. Oh my god we are the fancier girls now.
Hello. Hello. How'd I get on that again? Hold on. Get me in that tank that was fun.
Control. Oh. Is that a gay balloon? Oh it's a hot air balloon.
Let me put you out of your misery. It's screaming.
How do you get them to drown? I don't know. If they are on cars you can throw them to the water.
Oh okay I gotta burn this.
What? Is that a hank? Right hold on. There's a spider behind me.
I'm a tank. I'm a tank. Don't go right. I've definitely drowned one there.
Bro the creatures are so funny though. Oh you can't stand on them. Okay.
That'd be funny if you could just run over them.
Ha. They're very fast. They are. There's so many.
All right if there's like something on the side of a belly then just grab it.
You know what? Oh fuck I can't kill you with this. How many do we...
Defeat tanks. I've not even came across a tank yet. Out with the old.
Historic buildings. False advertising. Burn billboards.
Destroy spider tanks. Oh I see. All right I guess we become tanks then.
Oh my god they do spider tanks. Now they have tanks.
Now hold on a minute. They're so funny. We're like Avengers level threats.
Why do they have tanks? Are they hurting us? I don't know. I don't think so.
Yeah we have health now. There she is. All right hold on. Maybe we are the real
spiders all along. Oh Chinese can be a little tank. I'm a tank. I'm a fight back if they want
to fight with tanks I'm a tank. Wait did we do it? I'll show them a juggernaut. We can destroy the
buildings. Challenge complete. Oh wow that was easy. We did it. We're so good. Wait there's another
spider here. Oh my god do you see this like the spider statue of liberty? Oh destroy it. Destroy
it. That's a landmark. Hold on. Can I snipe it? I'm shooting it. I'm shooting it. No okay right
I'm gonna I'm gonna be a little tank and then I'm gonna throw my bullets at it. Yeah throw it.
Shooting it doesn't do anything too. Yeah it's not really working. Allow me. I might be small but
my oh no my tank is far too short. Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute. I'm gonna see if I can get to
the edge. Come on. Come on. Oh no that's so tiny. That's so tiny. Nice. Is it gonna hit? Aim higher.
Uh I don't I can't see anything from up here babe. Is it working? Uh aim straight up.
That's like as high as I can go. Oh shit. I literally cannot see anything. Did we get an RPG?
We must get an RPG this map. Come on. Get me an RPG right now. I'm off. Wait we have to collect
30 spider hats and accessories. I don't know how to. When you kill them if you look at the floor
there's so many like little hats. Oh and we can just take them? Yeah I can. Oh I love robbing them.
I love robbing their dead body. We're pillaging. Oh I see that's how you get the hats. Oh yeah.
Oh my god I love stealing from spiders. Oh did we already go on this side? No we must
though because there's destroyed buildings over here. Oh my god. Okay there's like two main islands.
All right I'm gonna look for hats though. Their screams are so sad. It's okay.
Remember what they did to us long ago. Exactly. What did they do actually? Yeah what did they do?
Oh okay. I'm not gonna accidentally go through that. Does anyone have any later fluid? I can tell
that we are doing monsters. No. Why do you say that? I don't know. I don't know. This is a hunch?
Maybe I'm just being self-conscious. It's okay. You're not doing anything wrong. Yeah you're right.
Yo dem steal their hats. Ah big spider. Story balloons and boats. Don't mind if I do. Oh my god.
My aim is so short. What's with the balloons? Oh wait you can actually shoot the balloons? Yeah
yeah if you shoot the balloons it's a part of one of the milestones. We need like four more balloons.
I shot two. I can't. A boat is as well if you see a boat in the water shoot a boat.
Okay. Finest cuisines. I can see one boat. Okay I know what the historic buildings are.
Oh the billboard. What a pathetic little ship there. Oh no for your sadisticness is coming out.
Wait what is this? I got a burrito. Oh yeah yeah yeah like we have to destroy all the
we have to get the foods too. The cuisine. Oh for the billboard? Yeah you have to on the buildings.
Yeah they have to be on their buildings. This game is like way bigger than I would ever have
expected. Like way bigger. It's really big. It's very silly. It's a nice thing to do though. Although
I'm starting to feel a little bit bad but like hearing them scream and run away I'm like oh
I'm like you're starting to kill a needle of heart strings. Too real. Too real stuff. Yeah I'm
like I don't want to like start wildly attacked though. Okay there's a bunch over here. Oh there's
like challenges on the antenna. Oh in order to say oh my god that's so cool. Some of the
companions collect spider heads one more. Oh kill we have to kill one more spider.
I got it. There we go. There we go. It's so like when you destroy these buildings inside there's
the crystals. Oh right destroy every single building. Gotta I'm beating the absolute crap. Okay
say no more. Say no more. The crystals are in there. Okay that's cool. We will deal. Are
they in a particularly colored building? Yeah but like you have to finish the objectives in order
to open them. Oh yeah. Okay I see. Purple building. Purple building. Okay I see.
Purple building. Demolish historic buildings. Okay this was a historical building. Destroy balloons
and bullets. Did we liberate statue one? I can't figure it out. Destroy it but maybe later. Oh did
we not destroy all the history. Oh no I think this is the last historic building. Hold on.
What the Statue of Liberty? There is a and maybe a the lighthouse. I saw a lighthouse earlier. Oh
look at that spinning thing over there. What is that? Okay we need one more. What you see in it?
It may. Oh there's a purple one. Okay one more historical building. The historical building's
just like older than the other buildings if that helps. Oh there's one over here. They got that
detail too. Oh yeah yeah kill it. I'm killing it. I'm killing it. I think that's it right.
Still cannot destroy it. I think oh I guess not. I don't have any more ammo.
I don't even know how you supposed to push them. What building is it? But it looks destroyed.
Huh.
Do you know how to destroy a sister? Yeah. Yeah I do. Thank you. Destroy everything.
Wait you have to defeat tanks in the RC tank. Is it tank tank? Wait would it be faster to
blow up the tank? Yeah probably that's what they're for. But how do we see the other tanks?
Yeah that's the way faster. Oh really? Wait how do you become a tank? I'm gonna destroy everything.
You have to find the in the queue if you press Q. You can find the tank control. It's like a
little cart. Do you control? Oh look it's another recipe. For the witch thing? Yeah look. Oh my god
it all connects together. Oh so you have to like keep going back and forth? I mean the adorable orange tank.
Did I just see? Oh this. Rad cola. Keep smelling a screenshot. Rad cola. Okay. Do we have to
write that down? Do we have to write the recipe now? We have three more spiders to drone. Maybe we
should screenshot it. I screenshotted it. Okay nice. Okay. What other objectives do you have to
defeat? We still need to drone them. They are not making this easy. I need another. I need to get
a drone to another one. How do you drown them? Throw the cars. They'll be attached to an item
if you use the wee scanner and then yeet into the water. That's messed up. Okay. Okay we need to
also burn two more billboards. Why'd they make this so like I don't know controversial but this
seems difficult. Like there's so many layers to. You have to watch yourself slowly become the villain.
Yeah you live long enough to become the villain. Yes. There's a billboard. Oh wait no I think it's
already destroyed. Already burned. Okay okay okay. I need we need to drown one more bitch.
Throw their cars into the ocean garden. I think that bridge that we can't get past this one that
needs 20 freaking rocks is where everything else is so I don't know if we need to go back to like
another teleport basically. I see. That would be my guess right now because I don't have one more
scooter. Oh my gosh. There's billboards over there. Oh I found one more billboard. Oh you did? Yeah.
I sort of break everything. A historic building. A historic building. I can't see.
There's any other cars here so I can drown one. One more billboard and we unlock another
like purple. Oh I drowned one. Yes sir. What did you unlock? Okay I opened this one. Oh nice nice nice.
Beat it up. Destroy it. Show us his balls. Show us his balls. You're stuck.
So that's their team. So we can go back to that haunted mansion and do the bottom door on the
floor. Oh I found another billboard. Wait. Oh you got it. That's the last one. You did it. You did it.
You did it. We got another one. Oh my god it's all coming together. It's all coming together now.
Hold on. Oh my god. We just didn't drown one more little bitch. No no. Fuyu did it. She did it.
She drowned it. She drowned it and we got it. Oh yeah. Oh we didn't destroy another like balloon
thing then. Okay. Is this a historical building? I think it is. Yeah. I just see you guys.
Did we destroy a historical building? There we go. There we go. Okay. Okay. I see I see.
Okay that's 15. How much is the bridge? 20 or something? 20. Oh that's rough. I think we
might have to go back to the witch's culture. I want to go back. Also your your body friggin.
When you're hitting things with the newspaper your body just contorts.
Dude there's no weapons. There's no more air balloons. I think it must be visible behind those
buildings from back there. Yeah. Maybe. Also we missed the chance to defeat tanks with the tank.
Oh it became like 5. I think we maybe need to restart it. If Emmy goes to one of the
antennas to restart the mission. Yeah. There might be more tanks in the next town over there.
Then tennis is over here. There's one over here. Oh yeah. It like starts a mini game. Yeah.
And we can redo it. Destroy spider tanks. Okay this is the one. This is the one. We're strong. Yeah we
can redo it. Oh that one? Yeah. Right. I'm going to turn into a tank and then we should get to tanks
everybody. Okay. I'm ready. Wait hold on. I spawned me all the way over here. Are they serious?
Should I let you left it? Oh it gets left on the right. I'm very slowly coming over.
Oh you can recall it. We're coming in. We're coming in rolling. They see us rolling.
Oh look at that. Okay that makes sense. Catch me riding dirty. Oh wait there's a recipe in there.
Okay okay. Okay four years ahead. We're coming and do that right okay. So now once Emmy activates
the mission we'll all jump in tanks and go mental. Yay. Yes it's time to explode.
I'm very slowly coming. Oh I mean. I'm actually riding dirty.
I'm not seeing it. I'm not seeing it. Okay ready? Ready. Yeah I did it. Oh it took me out.
Where are they? Are you jogging me? I took me out of the tank only to. Oh there see I'm going to see
them. Oh why am I in the. I see them. I see them green. Should the green. Should the green. Green bad.
Green bad. Green bad. Wait it's not even hitting. Is it registering? Is it working for you guys?
Yes but it's not a single kill. Very badly. One kill hit. You have to hit them multiple times.
I'm spraying and preying. Okay. Okay that's three. That's three. That's three. Two more. Two more.
Two more. Two more ladies. Okay. My tank exploded. It's okay. Oh my tank's gonna die too. Where are
they? They're in the center. Oh. Yes. Let's go. Oh my god it's clicking. I think it's clicking.
Oh my god. Right now we can go be up a building. Whatever one it may be. This one. Oh that pink one.
The pink highlight. Yeah it's like a green question mark on the map. Oh I see it. I see it.
Oh my god. We did it. I'm balling. So that's it. We're playing worlds of tank there.
Nice. For an early access game this is massive. This is early access? Yeah this isn't even the
full release. This is like 0.6. They're not even close to implementing all the stuff they want to do.
Oh money. I just stole money from a spider. Oh my god. Wait no it was Emma. Oh.
How is there not one boat that we can shoot? I don't get it. That's what I'm saying.
Maybe there's another objective or there's another mini game too. That's just like kill
spiders. Maybe some hot air balloon ones will appear. Right? It's over here. I think they're shooting
things at us. What? There must be soldiers. Soldier ants. Go away. No ants. Okay. No scooters.
Same thing. Yeah this one's just for the soldier ones. Should I activate it?
Yeah. Just to see what'll happen. Kill soldier spiders before the tamer expires. Oh this is
another one. Run! Run! Get them. Get them. Get them. Get them. Get them. Hunt them down. Hunt them down.
Make them regret being born. Make them regret being born. Oh my god. They're in tanks. They're
in tanks. Oh my god. Everyone's getting burnt alive. I have terrible aim. It's over. Geneva
convention's out the window. I'm on a rampage. All right. Okay. We've got seven. We've got seven.
We're doing it. We're doing it. We're doing it. Come on. Keep going. Oh fuck. Okay 15. That's 15.
Satisfying. I feel like this is wrong. They're trying to run away. It's a great way to release
stress. Challenge complete. Right. That's another one. Let's freaking go. We're doing it. We're doing
it. We're doing it. Yeah. Right. I guess what did we do that for? Nothing we can do. That didn't
unlock anything? Yeah. Unlock. Right. My controversial take is we need to go back to the
witch's place now to unlock more. I know. It was controversial. I'm sorry if we get cancelled
over that statement. It is what it is. We're going. We've got to go. We're ready. Okay. Enter
port. Ready. Only the host. Oh right. Okay. Immerse tank. Going. Right. Hydration check. Hydration
check. Oh water. Drink your water. I don't have water. But I have a droplet device. Cheers.
What? Cheers. Cheers. Come fast. Oh look at all the stuff that we can go to though. Like before
we see that. Oh my god. Let's explore. Yeah. Yeah. Explore the ship. That's so much. Okay. It's
finally clicking in my head how this game mechanic worked. I'm so sorry. It took me an hour and a
half. This is literally a Metroidvania game. Oh what? You still work bench and
armory to equip. Oh to upgrade. Hi Darwin. You found your way in excellent. If you discover
Yeah. You have a lot. Oh wait. Oh well. Oh we can. Okay.
Oh upgrade.
They're absolutely all over this lab. Don't be surprised when you open a like a.
Oh. Oh they're. Yeah. Again. Again. Again. Again. Again. Oh my god. Get my close them because
we destroyed them. Oh. Oh shit. We got pack a punch in this game. Like call it like literally
called zombies. We got pack a punch. We can upgrade the clipboard so it's extra like damaging or
something. What do you guys want to upgrade? I don't know. We just got an extra. Oh we can
be open this now. I'm opening everything. I didn't say the locker is um thingy. Compound eggs.
Let's go. Close it up. Okay. And then go here. I'm with the science team. The science team. We're
going to the science team. Oh only the host can do upgrades. Where's the upgrade? Oh I have a laser
assault rifle. In any any Darwin. Oh there's a spider here. Where? Oh I beat him up. Nice. There was a
spider. Oh this is like that crocodile game where you grab like three ball things. I don't
know if you guys have that. Okay let's make a new weapon with the blueprint then. Okay.
Oh there's a spider. Teleporter. Great new equipment. Oh the Molotov.
Oh. Oh do the Molotov. Oh there's shurikens. There's shurikens. We can be ninjas.
Amy we need your help. What do I do? We need you to press this button as a host.
Which button? Over here. That's his print the hollow Molotov. I did it. Yeah. Some assembly
required. Objective completo. Yeah. We should. Okay we need two more. We'll have access to the
Molotovs. If you press Q. Have you named Molotovs? I got six. Oh let me check.
Let me check these buttons. Did you also do that? Let me see. Molotov.
Excuse me we'll set burn the lab in a very unsafe way. Ah spider. I'm just arcing. Okay.
Okay we need one more. One more? Oh yeah can you upgrade anything for in our armory thing?
Uh. Here here here. Wait I forgot where it was actually. Over here and then we'll have 20.
Yeah yeah yeah here here here. And then we're. Wait oh oh. And then we can run fast. Huh? Run fast?
Use the work bench to upgrade. Here here here. You can upgrade things. Yeah. If you upgrade or
click forward we'll run fast forward. Huh? We have 20 now. Oh we did it? Yes. Yes. Oh my god. Wait
so we go back to the giant world? We can upgrade basically everything. Yeah. So everything becomes
eh? Who's breaking the walls? Oh my god I just got splooged on. Literally didn't that to me. A spider.
Ew. Sorry it was my ink I got excited. Oh sorry it's okay. Don't worry.
Actually if you're an eel can you? No. Huh? What? Can you slime if you're an eel?
No. That's not what eels do. I think those are a little slimy. I don't think people know a lot about
how eel slime. Oh wait we can open this. Wait come here. But you know you see the 20? Yeah.
Yeah. Let's do it. Let's do it. Let's do it. Oh my god. Yeah. You get that generator thing. Literally a
Metroidvania. The command wing. I think we can take this. Oh wait. Let's open this. There's already
dead spiders in this area. I don't trust it. Kill zombie spiders. They're not dead. They're not dead.
I'm dead. Spawn Kimms. Spawn Kimms. Welcome to the command wing. There's three. There's
three zombie spiders we need to perish. Or nor. Or nor. Right here. We're going to show you numbers
in chat right now. Wait what? Oh they're dying near each other. They've come back to life. Wait they
just keep coming over and over. Oh sorry. They're dying near each other. I think we take this to the
hold on. I'll go. Oh there's another rich. So it's all of them restarting. Or just. Yeah. Oh they're
dead. They're more than dead. Oh they are back. They're like back in the whole like in the the
captain's chair and everything. Yeah. You know what Newt time. There's crew at tank time. We have
Molotovs so I'm just burning everything. Oh my god. Just burn everything now. Burn it all then.
Oh my god. There's so many. I don't see any. Not really any either. I'm just hitting stuff with them.
I mean I'm hearing them getting burned. That's why I use the flamethrower a lot because
it just burns them. Wait why is that? Oh there's one.
That's this. Beat him up. Beat him up. Beat him up. Beat him up. Beat him up. Beat him up.
Beat him up. We have a tracker. We can just find them easily. Oh there's a blue.
What would they can hear? I would like to say something.
What a kid his director's currently stuck in lockdown fuck you
How dare they?
How dare they I can't wrap this freakin tape. Oh, give me the tape
Is the glass really in the way right now? I don't know where it's too. Oh
I think it's a blue. You can shoot the glass. Oh, there we go
I was like burden like to send her so I have nothing screen. Oh
Oh
Guys chest chest
Chest one more compound X my yes, what chest?
Yeah, this chest had a oh, did we kill a zombie? I think so
We're any two compound now, so
Oh, we do with the compound
What?
No, I got a compound or zombies
I
Think real
Well, we go back to the teleporter again to the new areas because we've unlocked so many new things like in the other area
Okay, okay, okay. Where's the top serotonin on my brain from unlocking things?
Yeah, I don't think there's anything else we can do here. Did we ever find all of the dumbbells?
Yes, we did
Oh, so I unlocked something so now we can shoot with this, but I don't understand it
I don't know where we're supposed to shoot with this
Can we shoot the whole spider planet down? No, wait
Mass extinction event
That looks I saw I I don't know how to get I opened up a teleporter over here
So like you can control it from above
Whoa, look up bird's-eye view. Oh, no
You just get it from the screen. Yeah
Find a way through the reactor blast. Oh the reactor blast or where's the reactor blast door?
It's probably this whole thing the red stuff these red things right here. Oh
Oh, I know the reactor doors to the right there at three o'clock. Oh, maybe oh
Can you and destroy that?
Can you aim? Oh, I can see the the thing turning around very slowly. Yeah, okay
I'm aiming. I'm shooting
They really couldn't have made that any slower could they hmm. No, it's very slow. It's okay patience. I feel myself aging
I'm getting
Slowly, but surely are we supposed to break the window?
Don't
What if he's well, I may actually kill some spiders in the room at random. So that night. Yeah
Okay, okay, just a little bit more a little up a little up. I think that's good. That's enough. Just go a little up
Excuse me with the cold spider behind us
Is it working I don't know what we're supposed to do
Was there an instruction?
Yeah, you can talk to Darwin you can talk to Darwin the way through the reactor blast door
Some disassembly required. I just there's no way that's supposed to be able to aim all the way over, right? Unless it's
I'm no convinced I'm no
curious
Reactor blast control emergency action
It's great
You need to I don't understand
Says reactor so maybe we shoot this yeah, the door. Yeah, that's what I was thinking, but I don't know how to aim it
Hold on
it told us
It told us to that a Darwin said for this door imagine little
Ants a little spiders and tanks, so I think we have to go back to the giant test world and destroy it I
Don't know Darwin randomly just made a reference to the we answered tank
That was my one and only attempt at small talk, and then that's it. He doesn't say anything now. Oh, oh
Yeah, can we tell?
No
Destination control air
Wait, no way that worked
100 I
Yeah
Burning them in case there's a spitter in them. Oh, and there is
Here we reactivate the teleport control room
Long way around
This room will be
You sell and sir. Oh, there's a spider here. You'll be spider thing
That's good. Nope
You'll need to locate three out the six. Oh fuel cells and calibrate the gate
Okay, I found one I found one. Oh
Here's in the oh, I lied so one of the fuel cells is in the
Ventilator system that connects to the reactor
Yes, wait that connects the reactor to the control room
I'm really bad at your actions the reactor core. I'm going to lock her. Oh, I just have come
Ventilator system, what about the others?
There is also a very large life form in that in that section
Yo, oh wait we can become a wee spider can't we maybe I think we can
Also, we need to put something in the reactor and I don't understand what is it. Oh, they're
Yes, I don't know where to get them though. Wait, how are you coming?
Only the host may perform this action begin challenge sneak through. Oh
Did you try this at me or not yet? Oh
Right sneak through
Everyone's right. I don't know. I'm just gonna cry. I hope not. Oh
Get ready to get attacked use the tracker to detect nearby spiders
There's nothing here for now
Wait, what? Oh wait, we're not to attack them. I guess not let them pass. I guess we're just trying to sneak through. Yeah
Oh
I don't think we can kill it. Oh
No, just run just run just run just run just run. I'm getting out there that things to be thought that things to be thought
Go go go go go go
Epilepsy simulator
Why are we hitting it slow motion?
I don't know. I think we're crouching. I think we're crouching. I think you're faster when you're crouching. I found it. I found it. I found a fuel cell.
I
Don't okay. We got it. Bruh that did not that was no
We're up here. No. Oh, yeah, we're in the control room
I like to be I wanted to kill it though. We have a teleport now. Oh
Spiders are not as cunning as they think scants are just many of the vindicators have stolen. Okay. We need one more
One more what?
I
Just happened
I'm river traffic captain's quarters. Yeah. Oh, there's a morph one here as well
We find them carded best of luck bitch. Not you, but
Oh, is this what is this another?
Teleporting thing. Yes, we can come in and out of this room as much as it please. No. Oh, no this this thing. What's this?
Yeah, it's helpful rich. No, but this what I'm holding. Oh
Sorry, this wait. What are you? I put on the ground at this
I thought those were key codes, but they weren't last time. I think it's just
Okay
Let me double check the other one. Maybe we should put them in the same place so we don't lose it. Okay
Complete vent challenges through the vindicate wait, there's more vent challenges like that
I'm just one of them
Another compound what 24 something
Ha
We need one more. Yes. I
Forgot where the last one is
What's his name the Darwin's Darwin's Darwin told us yeah
Oh
That's probably the room we spawned in. Hmm. Oh, so then there should be one over there, right? Oh, yeah
This is armory wait, wasn't there one in the armory? I've got a wrong
Another one difficulty hard right um, I think that our best approach
Just going for it. I think our best approach is just going for it
Right, I don't know if it's gonna like
Oh wait, it might go it might walk across hold on
Right, I'm gonna take a right if you guys want to split up
Oh, no, I'm a freaking fluid. I don't have any
That is an epileptic seizure waiting to happen that late
You're dead go continue on I'm going I'm going
I've got it. I've got it. I see it. I see it as long as the frigging spider doesn't bite more
Okay, I've got it. I got it. We're out. Oh my god. Oh
Wow, okay, oh
We made it. Hey, no. Oh, there's a green on the map though. We can open up stuff. Oh
The more green right I'm gonna put the refuel
Serotonin is
Serotonin
Challenge, okay. Oh, I got 25. We did it. We've got 25 compound. I don't know what that means
That we can do but I'll take it
This is the wrong teleport. I didn't mean that one. Hold on
This
How do we get inside here? Oh
And I'm back
Compound X across across all dimensions. We need 35. Oh, how do I get upstairs? There's something up there, huh?
There's a question mark. Oh, like I'll do it up there. Oh, oh, oh, oh, it's one over here. Yeah. Oh
Five-head. Yes. Okay, and inside the chest is
Another compound on it probably probably yep. Yep. Yep. Okay. Yep
One more
But there's 23 in the ship according to like the top and total left
compound X
Hmm flamethrower. Oh
We're still the calzombie spiders, but we've only killed five so far. No, I don't know where they are
Keep watch of the vents. Wait, seriously
Are we gonna?
One of the reefland said look out for the vents. They went to go in here. Are they venting?
I won't. Is that what is that hint to what we're supposed to do right now? Are we?
Are we to be sus and then
Didn't I already do this one choose wisely
I have oh, I guess you have to choose
She's gonna go with choose what spider to go with what the spiders are gonna lead on spider. Oh, the spider's good
The body over there
I'm off. I'm
Keep going dead ahead. We can keep going dead ahead. What the wait what?
Huh, right, don't look at that if you're epileptic close your eyes cuz I don't know why they put that in game
Wait, there's so many red
Nations I know where it is. Oh wait, there's more than one
She found it. Oh, geez. There's a lot. There's a politician right there. Wait. We're to pick one
How are we supposed to know where it is?
What the fuck is this? Oh
Oh
Shit, I don't know how I've done it, but I found it again
I don't know how I keep doing this, but I think I'm like I think I'm the gamer instinct
I think I have the gamer instinct because I've got it again. Right. Can we does it automatically go in?
Yeah, so we need a
What two more two more two more more?
Yes, okay, do we have time right? We've got
Yeah, there should be one more from a vent thing and another one
Does it say complete on it? Yeah, yeah, and so we need what do one more vet and there should be one more like in the
Overworld for us to find I'm looking for an event elation
Is this a ventilation shaft?
Why maybe it's this one
Maybe it's this one. Oh
Is it this with this? Oh ring around well, we did do this one. Okay, really? It's complete. Yeah
What the flip
What the flip-flap did we duck tick-tock patty-wack?
Snicks. We can't find it. We gotta find it. We did this. Oh, oh, we did do this one
I said by the zombie ones
I wish there was a map in this ship
Oh, wait, there's a question mark. Hold on a minute. I wonder if there's a question mark. Wait, what?
I can see a green question mark in this room as if wait, that's one of the ventilation
We need 35 to get in there
Yeah
Are we gonna have can we go back to the mansion? I want to go back to the mansion. Yeah
I think that's the next step. Okay, go back to the mansion and then we'll call it a day. Yes
We need to find one more sparkly thing
Oh, yeah, that's right or oh, we must put them two rings. No, now we have unlocked stuff, right?
Yeah, there'll be yeah, there'll be a low on the map rate. Uh, does emmy have this light lantern?
I'm coming. It's coming. Yeah
In me in me in me
Target dimension manner. Yes
Wow
We're doing it. We're doing it. We're doing a race. Oh, is it I did every set. No, that's fine
Oh, no, it just makes every that just makes finding stuff easier
Oh, but the spider is all over again
Um
Oh my god, but there's so many stuffs like that. We can go into now
How do we lay their souls to rest?
We need to find another sparkly thing
Macpite Macpite. Okay. There's a really weird room under this. Oh, there's a basement. Yeah, if anyone wants
Yes
This is how we go outside
Maybe
I hope there's a shiny thing in here up on peaches. Oh, there's a green thing over there
Uh
Oh, it's here. What is this?
You found the shiny
I found the green thing
Oh, what is oh, it's a lot in my honor. What's going on? It's just splurging on me. Yeah more confound
Wasn't me
What is this one access the kitchen and balcony
Oh
That shouldn't be too hard. Oh the spot the shiny items aren't here again. Oh wait. I found one the basement. Oh wait. They are here
Wait, there are they okay from one. Oh, that's the newest one
Oh, yeah, where's the others?
Are they where they they were supposed to be at the beginning?
You jumped by a freaking spider. They jumped in me. God damn. Yes. They are there where they spawn. Oh
Okay, I found the I found the phone
Okay, that way that's so nice
Where was the other where did I find it? How do I go through this window?
Uh as a spider maybe break it or you can break it too
Okay, another shiny one. We are missing one shiny
Um, it might be in the cauldron place. Let me see. Yeah, I think that's the one
Um, I can't see it
But I think it was you who found out one specific shiny
I don't know where it is
I think it was uh the photograph. Yeah. Yeah. It was the photographing thing
The camera I don't know where that was
I got so close to getting through the door. I mean through the window
Oh, he's got this
I have to wait for the
Oh, I don't know you're the one that found the camera
I have no idea where it is. Okay
Where is it in the bedroom?
Oh, I got out. I'm sneaking around. I got it. It's in the same places. You got the camera
No, I got the shiny. Oh the compound eggs on the one. Hold on. Is that not what I was? Oh, okay
I accessed the balcony
Nice
Oh god, big spider
Or I think it was just perspective. Never mind
Okay, why is there I can hold a brew
Dude, I don't know where the
Camera can you kill the spider?
Oh, yes
Where did you read? Hold on. Hold on. I got really bad aim. Give me a second
Oh
Nice
Oh, we only need one more. Yeah, I don't know where where it is. Oh, I think his his goes here
Oh
Well, what's on the balcony?
Jeez
Jump scare a teapot
Oh
What's it?
Oh, the cauldron. It was the cauldron. Okay, let me see. I'll check all the drawers
What that? Oh, I thought that was like a person sitting. I was like, what the fuck?
They're waiting for you. There's all these ghosts here
Where the fuck is it?
I'm running out of freaking has anyone found the kitchen
Uh, the kitchen. I don't know where the camera is
Wait, I saw a camera at one point. Where a camera?
Yeah, I found a camera at one point and I didn't know what to do with it. So I didn't touch it. Where is it?
Where is it? I don't know. I don't remember now
Oh
Oh come here
Thank you
There we go. It's dead
Camera
Uh-oh
There's a mission in the basement for the old
Spooky uh one where you have to like where it keeps moving
Just so you know
There's a big spider there. I don't know if I killed it
And you didn't see the camera in here
No, but also I didn't look very well
Oh rich
Aw
The camera wasn't in there. I don't know where the camera was my brain hurts. Let me uh, if I was a camera, where would I hide?
Hey
You've already been in the bedroom. It wasn't in the witch's cauldron
I don't think so. I might have not
I might have not looked correctly
I mean like the camera would be in the bathroom suss suss. Why would you take photos in there?
Hmm
For fun
Just we didn't have access to the balcony either. Did we?
Yeah, but in the open did yeah
I I saw the camera on a shelf
I might have thrown it somewhere though
I found it. I found it. It's okay. I found it. Okay. Okay. I got a treatment. I don't know. I'm stuck in the basement
I don't know
Uh 29
How did it go?
Okay, so there's so four more things that we can do here
The so the in the basement we need to get cans of peaches. I've done six, but I couldn't get the rest the basement's done
Oh, yeah, seven. Yeah
Oh, okay, right then the stairs into the ray is that space
So you have to find cans of peaches. Yeah, literally
Okay, I found one more
If we can finish the manner I'll happily wrap up after the manner because okay, we're so close
Yeah, we we have to do three we have to get three more peaches
Peaches feet
Oh, it's me. Sorry. Oh
It's okay. It's okay. I was just trying to get in here. Oh, shit
I got in there, but I walked out. Do you not?
oh, wait, you didn't have to turn
How many more cans of peaches do we need three
free
Oh, I I think I found one. Yeah
Hitting with a okay now two more one more one more or an and then we do the
security spider game okay I hear whacking but I can't tell if it's you
guys or if it's like the game trying to give us a hint to like the location of
stuff now that was me don't worry I literally how do we get on this side am
how'd you guys get on that side this is just like all the way around you need
to do like a little 360 is that out the window wait if we can smash these
windows no okay I was gonna say that would be really cruel game design the
dev team we have a problem with you know we're so wait wait how about we do the
scary spider statue thingy maybe it'll reveal itself yeah maybe I don't even
know where the game one how you call it the weeping angels there's like one of
them in the hallway somewhere I don't know where it is but I'll try and find
over here oh here is I'm at it look where strong is jumping up and down on
the spot yeah okay so like begin one of us should extinguish basement candles
while evading the spider statue right I'm gonna stare at the statue then if you
guys want to if you guys want to blow on the I got one I got one I got two whoa
where's the rest there's two more he's not a threat I must be scarier when
you're playing solo cuz it'll be like yeah yeah we're just cheating I ain't
blinkin here's I got another one I ain't blinkin one more one more I said it's
only two I found it wait I thought I did oh never mind
it's not one more oh yeah I guess it did it what this is three out of four now
extinguish basement candles don't don't put it back on you we have to take us
to get the light away you put them back on for you no no fire no for ego no
for ego yeah yeah wait then how do you extinguish though they back to me or
the board do I have to turn off the lights how do you turn off the oh no it's
just 40 seconds left oh my god we didn't count it up well I count it oh I
felt you'll never guess where the last kind of pictures was it was it was fine
right we can open up the washing machine at the start now so that's oh my god now
we only need we only need to get a minute what is it three more of the
we're done the mansion well we try and finish the mansion and then wrap up the
cheeky knit week but we don't even know what the access to kitchen in the
who's access the kitchen where's the I'm assuming the kitchen is this where it's
right here yeah it's a twist I'll go make another potion and see if it counts
towards the oh yeah yeah let me see let me pull up my screenshot okay we did
not just didn't tell for and I don't I don't think so why would they not leave
that oh no so bring it to a simmer okay wait you have the recipe right yes add
one femur okay what that wasn't me I'm spinning a fever a femur a leg bone yeah
is there yeah this one the big the femur is the biggest bone yeah I put it in
and exploded I didn't like it well then try it again maybe it was something to do
with the fire and first all the bikes back to hon and us what happens when I
finish the femurs because we only have one more few oh no there's another one
here it should be good leave us alone tricycle we're trying to make potions in
here put it in oh yeah I don't know the fire do you have to put the potion here
like yeah use it on a fire you did you do two fires oh maybe maybe I had to
like break open the building more what do you mean break the building more is
it like incomplete no like maybe maybe I don't know how to explain it maybe I had
to like completely destroy the building so that it came out or something like the
fire did you do the two try to guess fire right the two fires yeah oh I guess
maybe that try I'm not on the trace I'm one with the tricycle there's four fires
that's all should you like them all no no no no first simmer it's just two but
yeah if I put it in explodes and do we have to do simmer do we have to do
something else that is a femur a femur is a boon yeah it's a dream
matching to a simmer add one femur stir until potion takes a rosy hue add one
to be a femur this is a femur where's the tibia maybe this is the tibia the
femur is the largest bone in the human body so everyone looks the biggest is
the femur oh yeah and it should have a femur no they're not the same look at them this is a
oh okay the weird one will be the tibia wait which one is the tibia where's the tibia
okay I don't know I'm gonna do a few few cheeky spins Denny you buddy I'll keep
you straight when it comes to biology okay okay I'm ready but they look the same no
no they don't look at the femur yeah that one the one that Fuyu is holding look at the hip
that's the hip bone that goes into it on the top of the femur so yeah right two fires in the simmer
before you put it in okay femur what the fuck I don't I'm why would it not register that I don't
understand I don't know simmer simmer fires is there any fire mentioned on your screenshot
or is it literally like yeah yeah yeah no it's just bring cauldron to a simmer it's too
yeah I think I had a break open the building completely
oh that's annoying yeah yeah two fires is the simmer then do we have to leave the two fires for
a little bit I don't think so I think the game's being annoying hold on and we never came out into
the circle oh how do we open the oh sorry I didn't call it wise I didn't call it wise
it's okay I guess I I think I did have to like break open the building more
do you want to go back or will we wrap it up I was gonna say are we wrapping it up
we're wrapping it up we're wrapping it up okay I mean I'm pretty satisfied with how much
progress we made because I was praying for having like seen that game go like it's just like
no way it works this time is it because foo use insane
food you are amazing you're you're it'll be the luck of yours making it work you have a spider on
your face it's okay I would whack if I don't want to break the cauldron I'm just gonna well there you go
hold on hold on it's still there I don't know I killed it mix in a magic potion
dude mix in a magic oh I have no idea where that's not working I think it might have worked
because you let it simmer for a little bit well you should have thought about that before having
impatient players I can't believe that it doesn't instantly work right away after we follow the
instructions well thank you for inviting us it was really really fun no thank you for coming
that was so good I didn't I honestly like didn't expect it because he threw the same things but
thank you so much for entertaining us as well like this is a hoot and a holler I don't want to play
this again this is really fun yeah you enjoyed it yeah I think if we made progress faster it maybe
would have dragged a wee bit less but I think now that we understand the core element yeah or I
understand I already get the core element now and yeah but thank you so much for playing with us
bye bye you guys have any announcements what do you mean do you have an announcement what do you
got an announcement hold on you go first no no no I was just thinking if there's anything like fun
that's gonna happen soon for you guys oh I can't leak a secret yeah I'm not allowed to leak it I'm
unfortunately I didn't know no there's no secrets that's not being announced there's no secret I
totally didn't leak it to Jenna before we started but no no secrets at all nope can't confirm or
no okay okay so thank you so much thank you I'm gonna jump out the discord and then wrap it up on
my stream but thank you so much thank you bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
we did it okay this is my favorite part when we're all still in beach of studio cotton about
strong illegal brah the freaking zombie spiders I was like oh they're cut the zombie spiders keep
coming and coming as in coming back um oh that broke my game because emmer's life um
oh my game completely crashed because emmy like god damn I'm on my foot
don't wanna be
great we did it the babies were the girls were so for Abra Jenna was so fucking nice I was like hi
and she's like thanks for inviting us and I'm like oh my god stop me being social
well saying that doesn't count because I'm really comfortable around Jenna and all that
like obviously as always if you didn't know I'ma let you in on some secrets
and some beach of her collab secrets you actually join in a voice call like one hour
before the collab so you end up like chatting away for like an hour just doing your thing
memin about and that that game wasn't terrible that game wasn't terrible I think it just wasn't
obvious unless I'm just too low IQ to comprehend everything we were supposed to do
it wasn't terrible but I have to admit when the progress was slow and it was like bro what are
we supposed to do it was like it was like legal replay unlock vibes I think it's not
now I don't have to say disclaimer disclaimer disclaimer hardly even nor
it is an early access game and actually the vealer girl's really lucky we actually got the
code for free we didn't have to pay for it feels good man well they don't stop coming and they
don't stop coming and literally me with a zombie I caught myself saying I was like oh they keep
coming and coming and then I don't know if you heard me smack my mouth I was like shut the f***
up like I asked them if there's anything that makes me them uncomfortable and they're right
nah go for it so I was like favorite kind of collab partner but I don't want to be f***ing
coming out we're like inking this and that and elemental p every two say yeah we heard it on
thank you for the super chat the booty lord reverse back at it again what we've got here
strong it's called kill it with fire too it's a cool labyrinth game or a solo campaign game
and I'm just I'm ready pretty good obviously it needs a little bit of cheeky polishing okay
Ned 418 thanks Scotty damn straight laying on that accent
have I stuck my tongue out and say that did you sleep strong yeah I slept
had a good ass sleep had a bomb ass six hours I was so happy like I was I was like I'mma
tuck myself in be on the entire day I did a lot of work yesterday um got loads of background stuff
done brah Juno's like have you got an announcement I like no no Juno I do not have an announcement
I totally leaked to her what the insider thing was I like no no announcement all thanks for
having us by Juno bye bye for you bye um but they were so cute that was that was a cute little
game I just wish it was a bit more obvious but that may not make just me uh my fellow Americans
I might just be brain dead that's all that's my only that's my only comment okay um I would say
that game though was pretty decent for a collaboration game it's really hard in my humble opinion
okay in my humble opinion it's rather hard to find games that are decent for collaborations
because they always seem to oh is she being all coming online today no she is because she's playing
a shooter she's doing a shooter week oh she is live oh it literally just went up right now it
didn't register tea um oh now it registers I've been I'm being they're making a mockery of me
they're making a mockery of me women gaming is an excuse oh you're not supposed to stay that part
out loud you're not supposed to stay that part out loud I'm so sorry for ignoring you during the
kaya but I'm yawing forgive me weeping good morning good evening good afternoon
shebe's on her fourth stream of the day it's break it's her internet oh it keeps break oh my god
what's going on over there mommy can stop leaking in both sides of the world it's fine
you're supposed to talk with them it's okay we understand we missed your attention I show
me little thing I've good news I've got two ASMR videos on the way um uh Poseidon a ASMR
collab is around the corner Yumi recorded her line so that's around the corner um and I don't know
if I'm allowed to cheekily say this uh but Juno and Shuyu said they wouldn't be adverse to doing
a one-on-one ASMR collab with me so I may also get to do a collab with them and I may say it for
that key um because it will be really cute um so I might be able to do that soon it's not going to
come out anytime soon because obviously it takes time to kick these things okay think think of that
cauldron okay think of that cauldron I was spinning that shit but they were like they were like oh my
god yeah we're totally done for that because they have three deals and I was like if you ever have
the time to do this I'll be killed because um I went with Juno was a did actually like I greeted
an ASMR collab with me she was like I remembered you still want to do it and I'm like yes please
that would be really nice um so don't break it I know don't break it good job that's supposed
to count for your hundred ASMRs left yeah it's um we're actually getting there uh I'm not kidding
I know the the audios haven't made it to light on YouTube yet it's because um obviously it takes
time and I have to wait on the collab partner's lines or after record new sound effects type thing
like I've been waiting to record new sound effects but it's been a freaking freaking storm
um the wind is too much and it was gonna get picked up Cartman oh did I sound like Cartman
thank you for collabing with me mommy is doing so good at making friends
your breathtaking I just it's nice to be social um because like uh we were making
not really let's say that out loud um right okay next subject whichy I'll see it I'll see it
another time uh mommy asked another VTuber's collab is too cute yeah like so basically whenever a DM
a VTuber I always put like I always put like I understand if your like agency don't want to
associate with those or whatever like it's absolutely nothing personal like I worded really
formally and correct like I am in my opinion um respect math haha um so like um I like always
just kind of like expect like oh sorry because we get we like we as in the other as in like my
gen mates in it as well uh we always like come back with like oh we literally just got told no
we're not allowed to collab with them or oh we're not allowed to do this and it's like we as is it
don't hate the player hate the game don't hate the talents hate management um type thing like we
completely understand it uh so it was like I was really surprised to be honest when Jenna was like
yeah I'm like did this collab with you and I'm like oh okay she so I'll take it yum yum yum yum
um I also get to collab with Catarina in roughly two weeks I got the witch doing a tough thumping
combo at a hotel bar a few days back what does that mean to take on another VTuber membership sub
should I sub on my main or on my fondly bosom out are you fucking fondly bosom all
what did what did you just go man sir I got the witch doing a tough thumping combo what's
the tough thumping combo what does that mean uh at hotel bar and what does tough thumping mean
like putting your foot down to the beat of the music
uh
seeing mommy happy mickle happy yeah um I do have an ASMR stream after this so I'll need like five
minutes to set up though you'll need to let me get my ASMR tools because I was putting them in
the recording booth in preparation to record the sound effects that I need for the missing collab
and then I didn't do it because the wind has been like going have you heard of the song
sub thumping no I haven't hear from jenna stream you're adorable and your voice is pure sick
but jenna is a bloody good oh she I'm gonna just tell you that right now she is fantastic so
you're in good company with jenna that's what I'm saying you've got great taste unironically um
that's as well for any foo you lurkers you've got great taste like she's a hoot in a holler
um like I said at the start of this a like the the call I was like
hey I'm Scottish I do purposefully like I don't see well and I don't use slang and
then obviously they asked me to use it during this stream and I'm like fuck yeah I'm gonna mess
you up with this accent I'm gonna beat you up with this voice um yeah when I get knocked down
but I get up again man I already self-reported like twice it's okay now you don't have to
member if you don't want to don't be jenna and don't be forced to remember seeing more and more
girls willing to collab is all heartwarming yeah it feels good man time for a membership yep no I'm
gonna try hard on ASMR for one hour 40 minutes maybe 35 minutes and yapper start yapping gets
scammed honestly I should just call my ASMR membership stream scam streams because I
present that I'm gonna do this one we heard the accent and all went fairly should embrace the
oh I do you like it do you can't let them say no are you just kind of guessing what's going on
half the town and you're managing a piece together at other parts because I'm using like nouns and
vowels and stuff and those vowels wait a minute no vowels and consonants or what put together the
word it's verbs nouns and adjectives there we go aye you're just guessing then between the verbs
nouns and adjectives what's going on likes are you squidding me right now disco man sir thank you
for the membership please enjoy your emotes one includes pregnancy please enjoy the pregnancy
emotes and adverbs is adverbs a connect to one one like also and that's it we're doing an english
stream together right today class we're gonna be learning a bit of english we're gonna be reading
a wee cheeky bit of Romeo and Juliet two star cross lovers forbidding one another a family few
divides their people and a mountain and by a mountain I mean the borders of Italy or something
like that isn't Italy it's in fair Verona or something pitch like that your accent isn't too
hard to understand yeah I I try and make it as clear as possible because like I'm really mumbling
or it's like when I'm treatment because I get really happy like she be calls it her bun voice
when she gets happy Barcelona she was sorry we just said Barcelona randomly thank you allie
lol there's no way I said that right allie nas alone lightning bolt emoji dragon emoji there we go
that's how I say your name thank you for coming to member please enjoy your mark um Scots are less
understandable oh than they think well I wanted to do a drunk stream but when I do when I drink I get
more mumbly and a bit harsher with like my vowels and stuff like because like with the r words
really like girl girl boy boy like I think you you would say girl but I would go girl really like
girl
yeah like lach woman as well um but yeah so she has bun speak what do we call you when you do happy
scots speak tizm it's just tizm I'm just so happy I'm just happy to be here it's just a raw tizm your
honor oh I just like what I get to do it's almost like I enjoy streaming and this isn't really a job
at all oh my god not someone asking what's sph on my freaking new short
no wait someone just commented on my sweaty feet short beautiful so's that toe scrunch in the wrinkles
look I'm here to provide what others do not that's all I'm saying I'm not gonna I ain't gonna be
uh telling you I ain't gonna be telling you nothing tizm speak got it that tizm
oh no hi pim pals sorry are we fun too yeah Scottish mickey mouse goldeners how do you
do mickey mouse in scottish ho ho he's always been a naughty boy no it like removes the accent
that's the thing like when when folk ask for a lollipop accent from me the only lollipop I can do
is are you coaching summer are you squiddin me right now I like the hydra thank you for becoming a
member ain't no kink shimmy should I try and do oh maybe I'll fuck you's up in the membership
ASMR I'll do that voice I can't really do it I was wondering how crazy be a lurid guest
they weren't restricted by YouTube wild well I'd be a lot more your lollipop voice is so good
it is actually give me sentences to say in the lollipop voice I'll see if I can do it
because normally I'm down here I'm down at this octave you know
hi asu I have terrible news I'm the Scottish one I'm not the American one you'll need to
cook again with that comment milf scrawny I don't know how to do a milf Scottish accent
oh you've been a bad boy haven't you you deserve some punishment I'll make sure to dish it out to you
one uh like that I'm a fraud my bad exactly
why don't you get a job what a sentence to say you've been a naughty leaf like it's time for
some punishment sound like that sound like that so you're becoming a giantist on that level and got
confused oh cutie funny even help I'm stuck step bro help me
yeah you want that is that what you want yeah I shall show you the fucking one don't you I'll
fucking get to you take it you sound like you've run a sexy fishing chip shop
stop that is like the best compliment I've ever heard you sound like you run a fishing chip shop
you know damn straight I do you want to know where the grease comes from my head when I'm
pheromone maxin and I ain't washed in three days call us reefling on itan
huh come with me reefling on itan
I think you I think if you do canny voice you have to like give yourself an artificial lisp
I just shine young I need to spill your drink clean let me let me clean it up
like ah it's starting to hurt hold on a minute it's starting to hurt
need a sloppy wet kiss goodbye or I don't care real
how do you guys five dollar redo is worth the chips in a crab state you want salt or
chicken salt with that which very good you like it oh my heart it's just too much lollipop canny
girl gen four real and true can you sing well or have how come you all know songs that I didn't
hear in the name of like I've never heard of this at all uh I've never heard of that title
um what kind of questions that's pretty solid of course uh um help me step bro I'm fucking
stuck in a canny get it pull me out yeah bam basically it's the Scottish version of that
so it's your choice you pick canny or you pick angry Scottish step sister make your choice
make your choice sorry I zoned out mama but I heard something about five dollars no that's not
how tipping works there's no I mean I can fantasy make you up some fried chips right now if you're
wanting thank you husky for the super chat no don't don't just because I say a number don't
freaking give me it angry lollipop sister you fucking worry oh I'm gonna say that one sorry um
you fucking idiot you could have ruined everything fucking get over here right now I'm gonna
fuck you up you don't believe there that's like angry angry little sis sorry sorry you ain't
only say that word now hold on a minute you know let's say the word back up back
like come on come on I was a gamer I was in cod lobbies relax relax I was in
fucking college at you lobbies you don't have it is you don't have the past
no unfortunately no I get I think I get one mistake like every six months get them get them
you've got plausible deniability real you're fucking re-fling
lollipop scott saying slurs real I can only think of cat uh isma from emperor's new groove
isma as in pull the lever crank wrong lever that that's what you think I sound like are
my gun mental or do you like when she's a cat it's all right mommy played call of duty she's
gonna say it exactly thank you remember you you called us no I didn't plausible no that wasn't me
can't prove it that's right get wiped out thanks mods get wiped out from existence
no no don't start up but I'll get offline right now don't you start up don't you start up thank you
I pour for the super chat then you start up you're just getting bent over my knee for a spanking
were you in modern warfare 2 lobbies I was in black ops 1 lobbies so it was a bit rough
it was a bit cheeky it was a bit cheeky I have to admit it was a bit cheeky a bit cheeky
can't prove it there's no evidence exactly Brian
like me he was an innocent soul but he loved TV his friend got him into anime and now he's a goddamn
weeb should I sing that thank you the beauty lord am I to sing that there once was a lad who looked
weeb is is that supposed to sing that I don't know if I was supposed to sing that but I sang it
so it's all yours now the ball is in your court I was reeflings have many names but I won't name
them here no someone fucking commented in another stream they were like oh I'm gonna leave now goodbye
links and I'm like what did you just call my reeflings
it worked too well not to be sung exactly exactly right here's the agend nation the agend nation so
we're gonna say a super thank you to emmers to fuyo cloverfield and to juna unagi I'm
probably gonna say that terribly wrong their links are in the description so don't be afraid to
check them out because we love people that are nice to us so tomorrow's agend nation
is what is known as in English is what's known as brain damage we are going to play overwatch
tomorrow yes we are we are we're gonna we're gonna play overwatch tomorrow we are and it's a stream
snipe I am going to make a battle night account that you can add and then I'll do the delete thing
yeah how do you pronounce goku goku
call me a weeb because I'm giving you the goku 9 000
thank you for the five
oh my god I'm sorry okay and next you're gonna ask me how do you say Vagito that's how you say
it's Vagito okay him with a goku 9 000 I mean I'm sure you guys can make that noise where you're
through surely do that again I'm close no I fucking love the comments that are like
keep going I was almost finished I'm like oh that's five dollars I've ever spent real Andrew
Vagito with a gulak gun galak galak gun oh galak sorry my damaged internet lag so you doubled
up in the glucking you can't escape it and if I if there's a horror game and I'm the main character
instead of hearing like you know what you hear instead you hear
and then if I catch all you hear
and then it's me thank you yes I'm muted my background music just to do that thank you
you're welcome and the clap of my cheeks real though like oh here's like a little
gonna like starts and everyone'd be like that's clearly her footsteps uh uh uh it's the clap of
my cheek because I get closer oh no she's grapefruit and that's such a good little terminology
for it you find her and she's just eating dinner and gulping soda the clap is alerting the players
they're winning instead of you died you could try again oh it should be an nnn game and then your
the objective is not to get them because once I find you it's over you're not like we are not
departing until your ink sack is empty thank you you need to make that your next game real
yeah the game's fully uh about to be wrapped up in a bowl and I'm really mad at myself about it but
it's the best I can do because it was the first time I've ever took on a project size I will talk
about it at a later date while it went horrifically wrong long so short it was all my fault because
I've never taken on a project that size and hopefully the gameplay resonates out a little
bit you've infected my mind I can't stop thinking about being put under I think my next hypno stream
is like two weeks away um I'm gonna try it with the smb and I'm just gonna have the
in the background when I start off I'm not gonna do an echo or if I do it might be like the world's
slightest echo because it was a too strong last thing I'm sure it's gonna be like that one vampire
game I do oh the microwave that you call the microwave sound as if I like freaking got that
produced in the corner should I get found on purpose or should I try to prolong the inevitable
I don't know what would be the reward at the end of the game for not getting done so
refling you twerp a late echo might be good as long as we're drained by the end of playing
off we have yeah wait are all reeflings male pretty much uh I make content that's like for for
guys and I've always kind of like done it that way hopefully it doesn't make you feel put out but
there are like a few female reeflings but they just ignore when I say male or like he him type stuff
which is like I mean I don't know I think that's pretty cool there's also pretty sure we are no I
meant sm what does that mean I'm so sorry you make content for male attention real I only play video
games oh masochistic I would never hurt you oh no I'm nice to you I like being nice to you it's
it's a mutual exchange of love survivor game you have to hydrate to avoid being joy today starting
where are you gonna make content for the other gender it's a shame I do sometimes get comments
like that and I want to like reply to them and just be like I'm sorry and here's the explanation why
but at this point like you know I've streamed every day I've produced how much content with
he him and I'm just like I'm so sorry to disappoint anyone who is looking for the the she content but
I'm not your I'm not your gal if you want she roleplays um I guess Fenya ASMR does them that's
not Fenya that's not the name there's a lot of like female for female Lebanese content creators for
ASMR and stuff like that and and I completely um what's the word
oh no no what's the word I'm appreciative that you're actually interested in even hearing
that content from me with my accent and all slapped on top I'ma leave it to the pros for the
the female stuff because I'm I'm here for the the ink for the tentacle
the thing is what the hell is in this
call mommy a puppy and see whether she's over the m oh and see whether we're the m
how dare you yo was good Johnny uh uh redirecting into sheebie because it's the end of stream to
he I'm about to do membership ASMR and I didn't write the script I lied oh you thought there was
going to be a script I fucking lied and
yeah never do it that accent just makes the flavor
strongy do you only attract male attention to get male attention what does that mean
no because I make content for guys why would I switch it up and all of a sudden be like she
her they them them oh I'm not gonna say that one the script just yeah forehead mummy's like so
beautiful wait the members ASMR wasn't just the yep session that actually makes my head tingle
what one scam is expected I'm going to do a serious role play member ASMR so when he said
never can I do it for I'm just I want to do it for 20 minutes and then be done with it
okay I am gonna wrap it up wrap it up I'm gonna wrap up your willy before we dive into this ASMR
am I even allowed to say that sorry I'm not sure that was a rather correct saying you my
refling darling refling are going to be 20 minute series ASMR than three hours of yapping deal
what a bargain hold on let me hold I am literally opening up the live stream right now to type in
a handshake emoji right now handshake emoji oh fuck this is my favorite thing oh there we go boom
um I am going panties none get wrecked um I am going to go and make a cup of tea and swap
up my microphones because I need to put it on the other focus right if you didn't know I have
two focus right setups one for the SMB which I'm talking to you right now through and then the other
one is for my ASMR mix and he set up my ASMR mic and trying it's really hard to get facial tracking
in 3d or like ASMR at the same time it is it is not possible how they say in french a not possible
n'est pas possible no I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I had to be this way okay I'm a read I
read into Sheevee cotton brum even though there's no R in her name um I will then take a few moments
and then I'll set up my cheeky ASMR okay abadi abadi okay so please enjoy sheepster she's playing
fallout new vegas viva las vegas make sure you're helping her I wonder what spec she uh did
I wonder if she did the same specs as me imagine if we had the same brain
you're destined for greatness oh what the heck that was so wholesome why why are you being so
why are you being so nice to me out of nowhere we are not vegas okay I give you kisses I'm gonna
give you kisses for how many compound x's which was 30
my fourth my fifth my sixth my seventh my eighth my ninth fairy I couldn't say that wait fairy and
kid fairy oh there you go fairy then you got some extra kisses because I buffed it off okay
I see you tomorrow and if not I see you in five minutes so bye I can't wait to bring
to just nuke your IQ into the ground after tomorrow I hope you're ready
um see you tomorrow I see you in five enjoy sleepy say hi to sheebie for me